pense aux sanctions occidentales cette
exigence de vladimir poutine faire payer
la facture de gaz russe en roubles aux
pays jugés inamicaux ces derniers
devront ouvrir un compte dans une banque
russe pas question pour le chancelier
allemand dont le pays est très dépendant
de la russie emmanuel chain vous êtes à
berlin olafsen ce rappel que les
contrats stipulent des paiements en
dollars ou en euros
oui tout à fait ici à berlin on l'a dit
on l'a répété cette semaine les contrats
sont les contrats il n'y aura pas
d'amendement à ceux ci puisqu'il stipule
que les factures de gaz doivent être
payés ou en euros ou en dollars ça sera
dans ces deux monnaies exclusivement pas
question donc de payer les importations
de gaz en roubles comme le souhaite
vadimir poutine avec le ministre des
finances allemand christian l'inr qui a
déclaré hier que la proposition que la
roquette pardon de vladimir poutine
d'ouvrir des comptes avec la banque
russe de gazprom qui n'est pas encore
elle sous le coup des sanctions seraient
examinées mais christian lindner le
ministre des finances allemand qui
précise également que l'allemagne n'a
aucune intention de financer la guerre
de devenir le tiroir-caisse de la guerre
de vladimir poutine donc une position
très ferme de deux berlin berlin qui qui
en cela sa ligne sur les sur l'est le
point de vue européen une position ferme
emmanuel mis l'allemagne dépend
fortement des emport de gaz russe
oui elle dépend fortement de ses enfants
puisqu'ils représentent la moitié ses
importations en gaz mais il faut savoir
que ici en allemagne comme l'a rappelé
le vice chancelier robert avec mercredi
lé les réserves de gaz sont encore
pleines à 25% alors il n'y a pas lieu de
s'inquiéter immédiatement même si la
première phase d'un plan d'urgence a été
activé une première phase qui consiste à
demander aux foyers allemands ainsi
qu'aux entreprises de réduire leur
consommation au maximum mais pour
l'instant pas d'inquiétude sur sur un
éventuel arrêt du gaz russe vladimir
poutine d'ailleurs n'a pas encore n'a
pas cessé de livrer ce gaz aux européens
pour le moment donc pas d'inquiétude ici
à berlin même si évidemment c'est un
sujet qui est suivi de très près par le
gouvernement merci beaucoup emmanuel
chasse pour vos précisions depuis berlin